s p elected a new leader Hunter Youssef
narrowly defeated Cape Forbes to take
over from Nicholas sturgeon and
yesterday he was voted in as first
minister in the Scottish Parliament and
today he appointed his cabinet well now
I can speak to the S P's economy
spokesperson here in Westminster that's
Stuart Hosey good to have you with us so
Hamza yusaf a new first Minister new
leader of the s p
no surprise really that he got the job
but was it a bit closer than you thought
it was going to be I wasn't quite sure
where it was going to be at the end but
uh you know it was pretty close between
him and Kate second preferences came in
52-48 that number again that number
again uh both Kate and Ash Reagan were
very gracious after it was announced and
Hamza has got to work very quickly he's
been appointed first Minister he's
appointed the cabinet today I've only
just seen the list of the minor
positions I haven't committed those to
memory yet but it's actually pretty
exciting why do you think it's exciting
then well if you look at the cabinet
you've got an extraordinary mix of
really talented relatively young people
you're Mari gujjon Marie McAllen Jenny
gold roof you've got people like Sean
Robertson and others who've been there
for a long time and know the parliament
you've got Angus Robertson still there
as the cabinet secretary for the
Constitution there's a man who was the
Westminster leader of the SNP down here
for years he knows his way around UK
politics I think this is a really really
strong team
the person whose name you might have
expected to be there who is not there is
Kate Forbes right who ran yeah very a
strong campaign she finished a close
second she was offered the rural Affairs
brief
I mean that's a bit like constructive
dismissal somewhat so uh no she was
offered the cabinet secretary rule for
Rural Affairs and a bunch of other
things this is a full rule in government
she didn't feel like she could accept it
though she didn't feel like she could
accept it but today the comments she's
made about Hamza and about the team who
have been appointed have been absolutely
first class I I think what it would say
is I know a lot of our political
opponents are trying to make Mischief
with this and of course I understand
that I don't think this is quite the
story they think they have just
gracious you know statement on Twitter
the facts are the new first Minister
offered his main rival a job that she
felt was too Junior to accept and that's
why she's decided to go to the back
Ventures that is why well I I'm not
going to second-guess the reasons why
she turned that role down but she was
offered a full job in government quite
right to she has chosen for her own
reasons not to take it and she's been
extremely gracious today in terms of the
way homs has gone about his business
appointing the cabinet do you accept
that there is a job at hand to unite the
SMP after what was clearly a pretty
fractious campaign of course there is
and it would be naive to say it wasn't
but let me put it this way Hamza is only
the fifth individual to lead the SNP in
40 years and this is the first contested
leadership election we've had in two
decades and I'll be really honest I'm
not surprised it was a bit spicy
but that contest is now over Unity is
now vital we'll have a UK election in 18
months with an independence campaign to
take up through the gears and of course
with the government to run so I'm pretty
confident you will see the unity and the
discipline the SNP are Fame for
returning rather quickly okay we'll have
to say the uh you know the proof is on
the pudding on that one
um if I may well I've got you I'm just
Keen to talk to you about a kind of lead
political story uh today in Westminster
and that is the government's plans to
try and move away from using what they
were describe as expensive hotels to
house at migrants saying do you think
that's a policy that's a sensible I have
to say the whole immigration policy
whether it's the pushing back the boats
dog whistle nonsense whether it's
putting people up in Old barges
it's obscene and it makes no sense
if the government was serious about
taking on the people's smuggles and the
human traffickers all we would hear
about would be intelligence and Joint
policing and board before
improvements we hear little or none of
that it's all dog whistle rhetoric about
pushing back boats it isn't some of the
reason we don't hear about that because
it's actually really hard to do if you
look at Interpol for example you know
they say look actually getting to the
people's Smugglers is one of the most
difficult crimes to crack because the
relationship they have it's very
transient people don't know The
Smuggler's real name they use burner
phones I mean it's very easy you know
for politicians to say look I'm just
going to click my fingers and we're
going to smash the game you know I I
don't think it's as easy as snapping
fingers and smashing guns I'm not that
naive but one can only imagine with the
resources of French government and the
UK government and the channel is rather
narrow that they can track boats they
can trace the boats they know where
people are leaving from lots of the
stuff done on the internet and I think
to be an awful lot more effort if that's
the intention to go for these people
directly rather than punishing refugees
and this is the thing that I find most
obscene in the SNP find
extraordinarily obscene
refugees and Asylum Seekers are being
demonized it's not illegal to be a
refugee it's not illegal to be an asylum
Seeker it's not illegal to come to the
UK to seek Asylum there needs to be a
bit more respect a bit more a
acknowledgment of international law that
we're a country people want to come to
for their safety respect that rather
than this demonization of people who are
really desperate okay thank you very
much indeed